monfort à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on voit
charles michel le président du conseil
européen il croit toujours à un accord
la france l'allemagne aussi et puis
bruno le maire lui il dit que ce qui se
joue finalement à bruxelles c'est la
présence de l'europe parmi les grandes
puissances mondiales au 21ème siècle
est ce que c'est vraiment cette bataille
selon vous qui se joue maintenant
écoutez moi ce que je constate c'est que
le 18 mai dernier manuel macro
accompagné d'un d'angela merkel pas
valait l'ours qu'ils avaient 2e même
conclu ou sceller un accord à hauteur de
rappelez-vous 750 milliards et qu'il
voulait proposer à l'union européenne
je crois que une macro qui manque un peu
d'expérience et un peu des tofs
semble-t-il viennent réaliser ou
simplement que il lui fallait
l'unanimité pour sceller cet accord
définitivement et que à sa nombre de
pays vous l'avez cité où les avait cité
le les pays bas le danemark l'autriche
et d'autres encore des pays baltes ont
notamment ne souhaite pas payer les pots
cassés pour les pays qui ont mal géré la
crise sanitaire la crise du copic 19
alors aujourd'hui bien sûr que les
négociations sont difficiles mais je le
comprends parce que je me mets à la
place des 27 pays européens qui n'ont
pas les mêmes enjeux qui n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes objectifs qui n'ont pas
les mêmes moyens non plus et à qui on
demande de participer finalement à cette
contribution extrêmement importante
il faut que les français sachent que
dans les 750 milliards il ya 500
milliards vous l'avez parfaitement
expliqué 500 milliards de subventions de
dons que la france doit récupérer si on
reste seuls chiffres là et on a bien
compris qu'il allait baisser mais si on
reste chiffres là la france de récupérer
autres de 34 35 milliards d'euros
mais elle devra elle en a remboursé 100
milliards ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui mails macron présidents
de ligues françaises
de plus quatre jours est en train de
travailler pour ruiner la france et pour
créer un impôt supplémentaire qui sera à
l'échelon européen
ça pose un problème et deuxième problème
moi que je pose bien sûr c'est à qui
vont aller ces subventions en france à
qui va t'il attribué subventions 14 voix
qui donne 7 milliards francs
je vois qu'il donne 5 milliards à
renault sans aucune contrepartie
alors qu'il y aura quatre 4500
suppressions de postes chez renault et
un et des milliers de suppressions de
postes chez air france
j'ai un vrai problème dans laquelle pas
si des mails macro et de bruno le maire
à négocier en tout cas s'il ya un accord
vous l'avez dit ça va peut-être se jouer
sur des concessions faites au niveau des
subventions
si cela se confirme est ce que pour
l'allemagne pour la france ceux qui
soutiennent ce plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros est ce que
véritablement ça ils peuvent considérer
comme ce serait une petite victoire ou
pas nombreux pas plus que de façon leur
point de départ où l'or leur objectif
initial aura été a été vous l'avez
compris rogner en grande partie mais
derrière tout cela parce que c'est du
cinéma
ce qui est en train de nous montrer
aussi que ce que ce que sont en train de
montrer en gueule à mme merkel et mm
macro il ya une europe qui ne protège
pas les nations européennes qui ne
protège pas les peuples européens qui
bafoue la parole européenne on l'a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire le l'état lit
compter ses morts tous les soirs le 27
février seulement le 27 février l'union
rappelle a décidé de lever son petit
doigt pour leur envoyer du matériel de
protection
l'allemagne qui a très bien géré manière
nationale 4 à bien gérer sa crise n'a
pas donné à masquer à ses partenaires
européens mais tout est comme ça mais tu
étais libre échange totalement
déséquilibré il
il y crée une concurrence loyale pour
nos filières agricoles industrielles
pour nos pme la dirait qu'il est très
amer l'état chez monsieur trump propose
d'ailleurs cela aux états unis et ils
bloquent l'accès aujourd'hui aux
travailleurs mexicains mais je crois
quand on est dans une situation de crise
comme celle-là on doit privilégier nos
compatriotes eh bien nous devrions
stopper et supprimer la directive et
travail tâche et qui aujourd'hui
représente cinq cent soixante mille
personnes etc etc
enfin l'immigration je pourrais le dire
parce que nous avait dit qu'on avait
créé l'europe pour la solidarité
on avait créé l'europe privée en pot
nous protéger de l'immigration c'est
pire que tout l'immigration vient aller
totalement sol et aujourd'hui on paye
pour les autres alors qu'on ne veut
payer pour les autres
la capelle j'aimerais vous entendre sur
les pays
frigo le parisien qui titre à propos de
ces pays radin ou économe votre au point
de vue là dessus je trouve ça
extrêmement méprisant je trouve ça
extrêmement arrogant
très sincèrement pour tous ces pays là
mais c'est bien finalement
l'image qui mêle macro nous donne depuis
le début de sa mandature
c'est le mépris des petits il est il est
12 ème y ont finalement de vendre la
marque elle et puis il est très arrogant
et méprisant avec les petits pays
nous n'arriverons pas de toute façon à
créer l'europe fédérale qui souhaitent
qu'elles n'auront pas les mêmes moyens
n'a pas les mêmes charges les mêmes
impôts bien aux objectifs la même
économie n'ont pas les mêmes filières
il faudra une grande d'europe des
nations de saissac nous demandons une
grande ordination qui s'élargissent avec
la russie c'est ça qui nous permettra
demain de pouvoir tout simplement nous
équilibré par rapport à aux états unis
d'à côté et à la chine de l'autre côté
mails macron dans ses mots dans sa
sémantique comme il le fait en france
depuis trois ans et demi maintenant il
est méprisant avec et les petits
d'europe
ils n'ont pas reçu ils n'ont pas retenu
la leçon du mexique
eh bien écoutez en trottinant comme cela
ils sont en deuil fabriquer des milliers
après des billets ou l'a compris c'est
une image mais des dizaines de petits
breaks cip à ce que aujourd'hui les
peuples en ont marre d'être écrasés des
peuples en ont marre d'être ne pas être
entendus et aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
angela merkel sont en train de prendre
le chemin tout à fait inverse sans
retenir la leçon de départ de la grande
bretagne
c'est bien navrant c'est une grande robe
des coopérations des nations libres sous
leurs ailes que nous appelons de vive
voix et marine le pen et le ratio
national
merci à vous jean la capelle pour cette
réaction je rappelle que vous êtes un
député européen de rassemblement
national